[Music]
in battle of the ducks news they said
dogs not dogs we're stupid
mm-hmm doc it's like you're saying it
like Arnold you know where you parked
the bits yeah the dogs rhymes with [ __ ]
you should have said that from the start
that's how I'm gonna teach kids you know
the dr. Pierre thing it rhymes with cop
do you need dog daddy no rhymes with Oh
submitted by basic [ __ ] the disasters
because you didn't your announcer voice
yeah thank you
the disastrous fire festival is trending
again after Netflix and Hulu released
simultaneous documentaries yeah which
one did you watch the Hulu one I got
Netflix one I tried watching it but I
fell asleep I only watch the Netflix one
I haven't watched a Hulu one but I'm so
[ __ ] ready do you guys remember the
fire festival imma let you take it away
too excited you say this okay you
remember the fire festival with ja Rule
yeah they were gonna do that bucket did
that sick ass promo video with models
and [ __ ] it was fake it was like [ __ ]
hurricane tan tan [ __ ] okay yeah we
supposed to be on island and [ __ ] and
they have enough money they just forgot
to like plan festival we're talking
about them again is because both Hulu
and Netflix have released documentaries
about the disaster of fire festival by
different directors mm-hmm damn how come
so many people want to roast this fool
I feel like involved business-wise
aren't the actual like people who did
the fire festival involved in that like
my release I'll explain but I haven't
seen the Hulu one but for the hula one
they did get Billy which is the
co-founder he's like the main one that
kind of I went down for all this Billy
Blanks no Billy whoever you went south
after time something like that
I thought was an actual kickboxer yes
actually what is he doing today like
doing he's still doing courses and stuff
and my friend he's a martial artist and
he he hung out with them and he was like
it was kind of sad because he does these
like group classes huh but at the end of
them he tries to teach it as if there's
like some martial art aspect to it and
he's like come on bro I know you're a
real martial artist but like what you're
teaching and doing is not really so this
dude Billy McFarlane he is currently
awaiting trial you pretty much going to
prison for this whole thing well he got
sentenced to six years in federal and on
top of that he's never allowed to have a
corporate officer position at any
company that's probably a solid idea but
in the middle of this whole thing like
he got he went out on bail and he was
already starting a new scam with someone
else is the face like and he filmed all
of it I'm so stupid
it's a really funny documentary because
do they have interviews on them yeah I
saw the Netflix is he like is he like
Spacey like is he weird or is he like a
normal oh no he's not being interviewed
on a Netflix one oh here's a thing
though like he just wanted like guys to
record him 24/7 it's like a it's like a
live vlog right like they're just like
recording everything so him and ja Rule
are just like partying it up and it was
like the most funniest thing on earth
because these two guys are like they're
trying so desperately to be relevant and
cool and they want to live that like
influencer life and in John roles like
yo man we're like Larry Bird and uh what
was that combo magic and
this reference Magic Bird the magic bird
yeah and he's like we're gonna like
change history white and black and then
he's like you got this hip-hop mogul and
you go no please
tech entrepreneurs and I'm like cool ah
[ __ ] first of all I don't even know who
the [ __ ] distant tech entrepreneur is
yeah and him it's like that it's like
two losers coming together to join in
form a pack and think they're making a
difference in what they got away with a
lot though for a minute like they
actually took it really far but you know
why though it wasn't because of them it
was the supermodels for sure I mean dad
Bella Hadid they had like well who was
the hayley bulb lately bought yeah
they're the top top top girls all I'm
saying I'm 24 50 cent of roast ja Rule
ago he did we did during the fire
festival if you remember his Instagram
he would non-stop rosro stuff but I was
just watching it like oh my god I'm
gonna have to look this up that [ __ ] is
crying my favorite part of the
documentary too is just listening to the
people on the phone with the like crazy
producers just when they're like yeah we
need to get a shot like we're gonna go
out meet these like wild pigs
we're not the girls hanging out with the
pigs we're gonna be here and then just
like here this dot dot dot like okay but
you know you know that we don't need
that footage of yeah right and they're
like we're gonna do it he's like that's
the whole conversation and then ja Rule
comes up and he's like if we want to see
the [ __ ] pigs
the ghouls want to see the [ __ ] pigs
we're gonna see so pigs
and then the next footage is them
playing with those pigs that swim it was
like I'd want to hang out with the pigs
but I was a very good move because
that's actually the clip that I remember
the most brilliant yes I remember the
hot [ __ ] with the [ __ ] fat pigs it
made me think that I could be swimming
with them the pigs
he's gonna get hides himself as a pig I
was gonna be one of those pigs and I
just gonna swim next to them and then
maybe drink the water that's near the
but there we go [ __ ] you creep there's
actually this part right it's uh it's
it's [ __ ] going like it's like a meme
right now but it's [ __ ] crazy like so
one of the people on their team he's
like this super clean cut are you
talking about Andy King Andy yeah he's
like a like a organizer
for events and all that stuff and he I
mean this guy's wearing like a cardigan
he looks like your typical like
middle-aged white dude like straight up
you don't think that this guy would hang
out with like these hip hop like a
Mister Rogers or something yeah yeah
he's super clean-cut right get this
though so there's this top there's this
moment where he has to take one for the
team he looks like that he has to take
one for the titties hanging out like
supermodels and John rule yeah yeah yeah
well he's helping organize all this he
awesome that's what he does though
Billy McFarlane with his first business
venture which is like this credit card
for New York I love this guy yeah but he
does events and things like that I see
so that's his job and then so Billy call
them like the last [ __ ] week and he
was like please I need your help so he
flew down and every day he said he was
going outside on the balcony crying cuz
it was just crazy he goes never in my 30
years of working in this business I had
to go through so much [ __ ] I went
through PTSD and well the craziest thing
is so they had like three truckloads of
water that was that was stuck at customs
in the end on the island and they
wouldn't release it and then Billy was
like Andy I need you to take one for the
team and he's like I've been taking a
risk yeah and he goes no no I really
need you to take it for the team I need
you to go there and go to the chief'
that the the customs officer and I need
you to suck his dick he's like you are
our gay Savior we need you right now
what he's like all right and he said he
took a shower he [ __ ] did some
mouthwash with that guy that's what I'm
saying
he could have believed he was driving
down to the office to suck some dick for
Billy yeah so he actually sucked that
day he didn't wake I officer was like
just promise to pay it's okay yeah was
the offer like already on the table like
that already established
I know what you're gonna want there's
this old man that you'll see that's so
mortified for the guy because I don't
think that offer was on the table I
think he went that he goes I'm ready to
suck your dick he goes Wow just I just
need the money man you have like 500
supermodels no no no we have one old man
it goes this is I'm gonna do this
he's just like getting really close to
the penis like this I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna no no even when he's telling the
story I just feel so bad friend like you
can tell like there's so many people
that was believing in him backing him up
they had no idea the level of what a
[ __ ] pathological lying son of a [ __ ]
he was okay I don't like he didn't want
to suck the dick but why do you have to
shower do bath wash for the guy he
doesn't have to do that he felt dirty
you don't have to prep yourself for the
[ __ ] guy did he put on [ __ ] lips
have you ever sucked dick before it was
fantastic
and I don't know why girls don't do it
more often it's nice see you're meeting
right here right now I'm JK me dick is
great women do it all the time I'm
taking one for the team you [ __ ] I
love the pig would you take it for the
team like well do you know how much you
love us right Iowa
I baby the side talk about this at home
okay you can forget it
yeah we all know you would yeah you're a
very dedicated friend now see this is
what's gonna happen you're gonna ask me
like would you take one for the team I'd
be like all right I'm gonna Park a man I
need to take one for the team
that's called management what take my
shower dude there's [ __ ] chip teeth
is shitty cuz I'm ready
haha and I got wisdom teeth coming in
[Music]